[Música]
Olá, boa noite a todos. É um prazer
estar com vocês aqui. Hoje nós temos bem
poucas perguntas. Eu também peço
desculpas que eu não deixei os links com
antecedência da live.
Eu tava ocupado trabalhando num detalhe
aqui da clínica que é meio urgente e
acabei colocando o link. Só agora
temos poucas perguntas, umas três
perguntas, então a gente pode até
discutir algum artigo hoje.
Deixa eu colocar as perguntas aqui para
eu ver.
Tô com muitas abas abertas aqui. Eu vou
ter que
achar aqui as perguntas.
Aqui achei
bem. Temos perguntas do Rinaldo e do
Eliseu. Primeira pergunta. Doutor, você
indica o zinco?
Sim, indico o zinco para quem tem
deficiência de zinco, né? não é para
todo mundo indiscriminadamente, porque
tem gente que tem excesso de zinco.
A pergunta tá um pouco fora de contexto,
né? Precisava saber exatamente qual que
é a situação que o zinco precisaria. Por
exemplo, homens que têm problema com
testosterona,
muitas vezes precisam de reposição de
zinco.
O Eliseu não entrou ainda, né? Que ele
perguntou da onde é que estava o link da
live, que eu esqueci de colocar isso
ontem.
Marielen tá comentando aqui que o link
que nós colocamos do Instagram
não está funcionando.
Deixa eu ver aqui se eu consigo achar
para colocar no grupo. Ah,
ah, das noites mal dormidas, né?
Deixa eu ver se tá aqui. Aqui. Pronto.
Deixa eu colocar lá no grupo.
Prontinho.
Eliseu está aí. Boa noite, Eliseu.
Então, vamos responder a sua pergunta
aqui.
Algumas lives atrás você mencionou um
efeito prejudicial que ocorre no cérebro
quando a pessoa mal acorda e já começa a
usar o celular antes mesmo de sair da
cama.
Certa vez, tive que acordar às 4 horas
da manhã para transmitir um recado
urgente a alguém pelo WhatsApp.
A fim de me proteger do efeito
prejudicial no cérebro, eu transmiti
esse recado via WhatsApp usando óculos
bloqueador de luz azul.
Acertei sim. O óculos bloqueia a luz
azul ajuda bastante a evitar a inibição
da melatonina que acontece quando você
olha a tela acesa no rosto, né? Quando
você usa o celular à noite ou usa
computador ou tablet, fez direitinho,
tá?
Película de celular que bloqueia a luz
azul funciona?
Não sei dizer, Eliseu. Na verdade, eu eu
recomendo você usar o aplicativo. Tem
uns aplicativos que mudam a cor da tela.
É mais recomendado do que você usar uma
película, tá? Eu não tenho certeza a
película funciona.
Quantas ressonâncias da coluna eu posso
fazer por ano para não cor risco de
pegar câncer? Não é ressonância que dá
câncer, Eliseu, pela radiação, é a
tomografia ou raio X. A ressonância tem
outro problema que é o contraste,
né, que usa gadulínio,
que é um metal pesado,
mas não tem uma correlação clara entre o
gadulínio e os cânceres de modo geral,
não.
Então isso, essa pergunta sua é mais pra
tomografia. Aí eu recomendo que faça no
máximo três tomografias por ano, tá? A
ressonância já não tem radiação
ionizante,
tem só eletromagnetismo.
Aí tem uma outra pergunta aqui. Doutor,
você indica o uso do iodo lugol 5%.
Eu tenho preferido, Eliseu, utilizar o
Yodo Kelp, tá? Mas em algumas situações
eu uso o lugol, sim.
Em algumas situações eu uso logol, sim.
Mas eu prefiro usar o iodo kelp porque
eu tenho um pouco de receio de que o
excesso de iodo mesmo com o selênio
junto não deu uma inflamação tiroideia.
Aplicativo celular que bloqueia a luz
azul só funciona depois debloquear o
celular. Sim, é verdade.
Para desbloquear tem que tem que ver a
luz azul.
É, mas é um tempo muito curto, né,
Eliseu? Não é uma coisa significativa,
né? São no máximo aí dois ou 3 segundos,
né, para desbloquear a tela do celular.
Até acho que nem isso. Vai dar menos de
1 segundo muitas vezes, né? Então vai
ser, vamos dizer que seja entre 1 e 3
segundos para desbloquear a tela do
celular. Agora a película eu teria que
pesquisar. Não sei se a película
bloqueia a luz azul, sinceramente.
Ah, do Logol, não foi você? Ah, foi o
Reinaldo. É, foi o Reinaldo que
perguntou. Verdade.
Não foi você, não.
Só temos três perguntas hoje aqui. Não
sei porque
eu acho que a culpa foi minha que eu
esqueci de colocar o link do
YouTube
ontem.
colocando em cima da hora e muita gente
não viu, mas mesmo assim as perguntas,
o link das perguntas ficou, né, mas não
ficou fixado. Esse foi meu erro.
Mais perguntas, Eliseu?
Só tem você na live, né?
Não, uma um segundo de luz azul já era.
Não, não, não, não é assim. Não tem que
ficar alguns minutos com a luz azul para
ter esse efeito negativo, viu, Eliseu?
Não precisa ser assim não.
Boa noite, Maria Helena. Você tem
perguntas? Porque a gente teve só três
perguntas que eu já respondi aqui na no
questionário.
O Rinaldo que fez uma pergunta sobre o
zinco, mas eu não sabia dizer
o qual que é a dúvida específica dele,
porque ele perguntou aqui se eu indicava
o uso do zinco. Eu indico para quem tem
deficiência de zinco, né? Então eu não
sei se ele tinha uma situação mais
específica para falar, porque o zinco é
interessante pro metabolismo da
testosterona.
Quando a pessoa tem um problema com
testosterono, muitas vezes é o zinco que
é o problema.
E o zinco é interessante também pro
sistema imune, quando a pessoa tá com
déficit de sistema imune.
Mas se a pessoa tiver deficiência no
sangue, é muito importante
também repor, né? Mas o Rinaldo não
entrou na live, talvez ele assista isso
depois.
Ele também fez uma pergunta sobre o
Lugal a 5%. Eu respondi que eu prefiro
o yodo kelp.
Algum problema paraa saúde em fazer
transplante capilar?
O problema mais é o uso do produto que
tem que injetar no couro cabeludo, né,
do tasterida.
e uso minoxidil, que o minoxidil para
algumas pessoas pode dar queda de
pressão arterial e a dutasterida que se
utiliza pode dar a síndrome
pós-finasterida, né, que é aquela
síndrome que dá depressão, queda de
ribido, disfunção erétil.
Então,
o problema em si não é o transplante,
mas o uso das drogas que eles utilizam
no pós-operatório para evitar que o bubo
capilar que foi implantado não caia.
Então, menos ruim quando você faz a
injeção dentro do couro cabeludo,
mas eles também recomendam que faça vior
oral, né? Aí que o efeito sistêmico é
mais intenso.
Ah, você tem alguma pergunta, Maria
Elena?
Os três suplementos mais importantes
para quem tem candidópolis, verde, alho
e orégano. Eu diria que são três dos
principais, né?
Pode pôr também pau de arco aí nessa
lista, óleo de coco,
mas eles são excelentes suplementos sim
para
pra questão de fungo, né, disbiose
fungica.
Deixa eu entrar aqui no
no examin.com para que tem lá os artigos
de nutrição.
Tem um artigo aqui falando sobre
ômega-3,
óleo de peixe,
melhorar a o sono.
Um estudo de 14 meses randomizado,
controlado
em participantes com diabetes tipo 2
e que foi dado suplementação com óleo de
peixe para melhorar a qualidade do sono.
Então, foram dois estudos separados,
conduzidos. Um estudo
crosssectional, que eu não sei bem como
é que pro qual que é a tradução disso em
português, deixa eu ver qual que é.
Seria um estudo transversal e um estudo
randomizado controlado, né? Então,
incluiu 25 27.549
participantes com um diabetes tipo 2 com
média de idade de 60 anos.
E os participantes relataram estar
tomando o suplemento de óleo de peixe e
está dormindo melhor.
Só que a diferença foi pequena dos dois
grupos.
E depois que os pesquisadores ajustaram
para fatores confundidores potenciais,
o óleo de peixe
teve um score muito discreto de melhora
em relação ao pessoal que não tomou óleo
de peixe. Uma numa escala deu 0,04
pontos acima.
uma escala de sono.
É, esse foi o resultado do estudo
transversal. Já o estudo controlado
randomizado, que aí foi bem menos gente,
foram 344 participantes com diabetes
tipo 2,
que aí tomaram ou óleo de peixe em baixa
dosagem, 1.5 g por dia, ou em alta
dosagem, 3 g ao dia, ou placebo por 14
meses.
não tinha uma informação muito clara da
quantidade exata de ômega-3 de cadeia
longa, mas a informação que tinha é que
o principal ômega-3 presente era o EPA,
né, que é o ácido ricosa pentenoico.
Então, depois de ajustar para vários
fatores confundidores,
os grupos que tomaram a baixa dose e a
alta dose tiveram qualidade de sono
melhor do que o placebo. Só que de novo
as diferenças foram pequenas, né? Nesse
caso foram 0,2 pontos acima na tabela do
sono.
Então uma coisa aí para se pensar, né?
Então omega-3 pode ajudar um pouquinho
no sono, pode ser aí um bom horário para
tomar ômega-3. Obviamente que eu não
recomendaria tomar ômega-3 só para
dormir, né? Mas se você tiver que
escolher um horário para tomar ômega-3,
parece que esse horário noturno é
favorável, porque vai ajudar um pouco no
sono. M.
OK. Então, se for tomar entre manhã e
noite, talvez seja uma boa tomar à
noite. Vamos ver se a gente acha mais um
artigo legal aqui.
Ó, tem um artigo interessante aqui. Como
comer muita
comida, né, de lanchonete, junk food,
pode afetar a saúde cerebral. É um
estudo controlado, não randomizado. Isso
aqui é um ponto fraco, com 29 homens
jovens sem problemas de saúde conhecidos
e que comiam excesso de lanches, né,
comida processada, ultra processada,
por 5 dias. E isso afetou
a responsividade do cérebro à insulina,
diminuiu a a sensibilidade,
à recompensa do cérebro e aumentou a
quantidade de gordura no fígado. Então
foi um estudo de 5 dias de intervenção
que claramente mostrou que comida
inflamatória afeta o funcionamento
cerebral, coisa que a gente já sabe há
muito tempo, né? Mas é sempre bom ter um
estudo novo eh confirmando isso.
Detalhe, o grupo de intervenção que
comeu essa dieta hipercalórica
hiperprocessada por 5 dias incluiu mais
de 1000 calorias na dieta normal deles,
incluindo acima de 70 g de gordura ruim
e 100 g de carboidratos.
E a ingesta diária deles habitual era de
2600 calorias por dia.
Então, realmente essa alimentação, além
de afetar o fígado,
afetar a resposta do cérebro à insulina,
né, diminuir a sensibilidade à insulina
no cérebro.
também afeta o mecanismo de recompensa
do cérebro, acaba ficando com mais fome,
né, aquela fome de compulsão. Ahã.
Tem mais perguntas do Eliseu aqui. Lá no
YouTube. Um dos alimentos que você
recomendou para quem tem micose de unha
é carne orgânica de boi,
frango ou peixe. O fígado bovino não
orgânico aumenta a quantidade de fungos?
Não, que eu saiba, Eliseu, a gente pede
para comer orgânico para questão dos
hormônios, né, que essas vacas, esses
bois recebem, né, o hormônio de
crescimento bovino e também por causa
dos antibióticos que eles acabam tomando
em excesso por ter esse sistema de
criação
intensivo, né, sem ter acesso aos
pastos.
Ômega-3 precisa de gordura? Se sim, como
tomar à noite?
Não, o ômeega-3 já é gordura, né?
Já é gordura. Se você puder
associarmega-3
com outra gordura saudável, melhor
ainda. Mas não é uma condição essencial
você tomar omôme3 com outra gordura.
Pode tomar normalmente, né? Toma as
cápsulas de ômega-3 com água. Não tem
necessidade de ser com gordura, não.
É verdade que a vantagem de tomar
suplemento cúrcuma sem piperina é ter um
efeito maior na moncose intestinal? É
verdade sim, Eliseu. Essa informação
procede sim. Aí o efeito local aí não é
absorvido em quantidade significativa.
Bem, vamos ver mais artigos aqui.
Tem um artigo aqui interessante
perguntando se fazer jejum intermitente
poderia piorar o ganho de músculo, né,
de massa muscular e de força muscular.
Os participantes nesse estudo foram 10
homens e sete mulheres, idade média de
25 anos,
e tiveram uma dieta com aumento de 10%
em calorias,
sendo 25% de gordura e 2,2 g de proteína
por quilo
por dia. Então, aumentou a quantidade de
calorias
e tinha uma de ATP proteica de 2.2 g
participantes
realizaram exercício de resistência
supervisionado quatro vezes por semana.
Então, o grupo que fazia jejum
intermitente
se exercitava antes
do meio-dia e consumia todas as suas
calorias diárias dentro de uma janela de
8 horas que começava pelo menos uma hora
depois do exercício.
Então quer dizer que eles faziam
exercício de manhã ainda em jejum e o
grupo controle existava no mesmo
horário, né, de manhã e comia pelo menos
uma refeição antes da atividade física.
Então a eles era instruído comer cerca
de quatro refeições por dia, sem
restrição de horário, né, sem o jejum
intermitente.
E a janela de alimentação era de 13
horas. né, em média pro para quem não
tava fazendo jejum,
ou seja, a janela de alimentação pro
grupo que não fazia jejum era 5 horas
maior do que o grupo de jejum.
Então, comparando os dois grupos, o
aumento na massa magra não diferiu entre
os grupos, não foi diferente, mas a
massa gorda aumentou mais no grupo
controle, ou seja, quem não fez o jejum
intermitente ganhou um pouquinho mais de
gordura.
cerca de 1,4 kg a mais.
Em relação à força de exercício dos
membros inferiores, eles faziam
agachamentos, né, com uma repetição
máxima.
Eh, a força do desse agachamento foi
maior no grupo controle em relação ao
grupo que fez jejum intermitente,
mas não houve diferença pro exercício de
bench press, né, que é aquele
exercício de,
como é que fala em português mesmo?
Bitpress. É o
aquele que você empurra com as pernas,
né? Eu esqueci o nome agora desse
exercício, ou extensão das pernas
também. Então, esses dois exercícios,
bent pressão da perna, não teve
diferença de força.
Então, a conclusão final que um grupo
que fez junto emitente ganhou menos
gordura,
mas teve um pouco menos de força nos
exercícios de membros inferiores,
que foi na no caso o agachamento, não
foi os outros dois exercícios.
E tinha evidências que os níveis de
energia do grupo que fazia junto
emitente era menor do que o grupo que
não estava fazendo junto emitente.
Talvez porque estavam fazendo exercício
em jejum, né?
E aí ele tá comparando com o estudo
anterior de quatro semanas andomizado,
controlado, em que ciclista do sexo
masculino
fizeram o hit, né, que é o treinamento
de alta intensidade.
E nesse grupo também houve menos
performance para quem estava fazendo em
jejum,
teve menos volume de exercício e menos
energia.
Ou seja, então existe essa evidência,
alguns estudos de que exercitar em jejum
pode piorar os resultados de força,
de ganho de força.
Então, estudo interessante aqui também
que ele tão comentando de 29 dias de
duração
dos
muçulmanos que estão passando pelo
Ramadã, fizeram exercícios de
resistência, ou seja, exercício de força
e que houve
uma diferença aí quando eles estavam em
jejum, por causa do Ramadã, eles
levantaram menos peso em relação ao
pessoal que não estava no Ramadã.
Mas são diferenças muito pequenas, viu?
Isso aqui não me parece tão
significativo.
Teve uma metaanálise publicada em 2022
que comparou
placebo contendo calorias mínimas quase
que despresíveis
com ingestão de carboidratos antes ou
durante exercício de força, de
resistência
e que isso o acabou provocando uma
melhora no exercício, aumento do volume
de treinamento
e que a ingestão de carboidratos foi
especialmente benéfica durante
volumes maiores e mais longos de
exercícios.
É, isso aqui fala contra então você
fazer esses de jejum, apesar que eu
conheço muita gente que faz esse jejum e
não tem muitos problemas por conta
disso.
É uma boa comer umas bananas mesmo. meia
hora antes de fazermos colação.
Mas a diferença é muito pequena, viu?
Apesar de ter uma diferença, essa
diferença é muito pequena.
Cúrcuma com piperina será bom para quê,
Dra. Alan? Estou tomando os dois tipos.
Com piperina seria bom para aumentar a
absorção e atuar como anti-inflamatório
no corpo todo. Por exemplo, para dor
articular, dor muscular,
como antiinflamatório, anticâncer. Para
isso, quando você usa sem a piperina,
ele vai ter um efeito mais na mucosa
intestinal, como falou aí o Eliseu.
Isso, aleg press. É, é o leg press
mesmo, Eliseu.
Exatamente. É esse seu exercício que
tinha fugido na minha mente. É o Leg
press
que lá eles chamam de outro nome, né? Os
Estados Unidos eles chamam de
Cadê aqui o exercício?
É o bentch press. É, eles chamam de bch
press, a gente chama de lag press.
Exatamente, né?
Ah, tá. Você fez exames, deu de CA 19.9
e Ca 125. Tomar cuidado com esses
exames, viu, Maria Helena, porque eles
são meio
complicados, tá? Não quer dizer que é
câncer sempre isso daí, não, tá? Eu não
gosto muito esses exames porque deixo o
pessoal muito nervoso que eles acham que
estão com câncer e muitas vezes não é.
Tá,
vamos ver, se a gente acha mais um
artigo interessante aqui.
Ã,
olha só, esse aqui é bem interessante.
Palmito etanolamina, que eu tenho usado
bastante neopea, e melatonina pode
ajudar nas enchaquecas. É um estudo de 3
meses de duração,
trollado, randomizado, 60 participantes
que tinham enxaqueca episódica,
suplementaram com pé, palmiton
etanolamina e melatonina de baixa
dosagem. E houve redução da frequência,
da intensidade e da duração das
enxaquecas.
A idade média do pessoal era 43 anos.
pessoas diagnosticadas com enxaqueca
episódica, sem ou com aura, né, que é
aqueles sintomas que dão antes da
enxaqueca, né, sintomas neurológicos,
sintomas visuais.
E o diagnóstico foi feito pelo menos um
ano, um ano antes do início do estudo e
o pessoal tinha uma média de três a
quatro enxaquecas por mês.
Então os participantes suplementaram com
1200 mg de pea e 0,2 mg de melatonina,
dose bem baixa de melatonina.
ou o grupo controle tava usando placebo.
Depois de 3 meses da suplementação, o
grupo que tava tomando de fato, né, o
produto que não era placebo começou a
ter menos enxaquecas, redução na
intensidade das enxaquecas,
duração e frequência.
E foi significativo, foi uns 36%
de redução,
tanto de intensidade, quanto de duração,
quanto de frequência.
Também houve redução da aura, né, que
são os distúrbios visuais e os outros
sintomas
que antecedem chaque como problema de
náusea, vômito, sensibilidade ao som,
sensibilidade à luz. Eu
teria misturado um monte de coisa aí
peia, curcumina, bozuélia,
daria uma dose um pouco mais alta de
melatonina.
Então, por que que eles usaram
melatonina, né? que existem evidências
de que a melonina pode reduzir os níveis
de um marcador chamado CGRP,
tá? Que é o peptídeo relacionado ao gên
da calcitonina.
Então esse peptídio, ele é sintetizado
em neurônios que induzem a vaso
dilatação e tornam os nervos mais
sensíveis, né? Então sabe que em xaqueca
tem muito a ver com dilatação
dos vasos cerebrais, do crânio, né? mais
especificamente,
então essa vaso dilatação provocada por
esse peptídio
e também essa aumento de sensibilidade
neuronal podem piorar a sensação de dor,
né, que vai levar à enxaqueca.
Então, medicações que inibem o receptor
desse peptídio são efetivas para reduzir
a quantidade de ataques de enxaqueca.
Já teve alguns estudos anteriores
mostrando a eficácia da melatonina
isolada para em xaquecas e uma
metanálise
de estudos controlados randomizados. A
suplementação com melatonina reduziu a
frequência, a duração e a severidade das
enxaquecas,
mas isso foi baseado em apenas dois a
três estudos. para cada
desfecho.
E os estudos anteriores usaram uma dose
bem maior de 2 a 3 mg do que esse estudo
que usou 02 mg junto com PEA.
E isso é uma coisa curiosa, porque
algumas pessoas têm dor de cabeça usando
melatonina.
Essas pessoas que têm mais assim
sensação de
tontura, né, ou de
sonolência exagerada com a melatonina.
Então aqui tá se especulando se não
seria melhor usar doses menores de
melatonina para essa indicação aí da
prevenção de enxaqueca.
Então tem estudos anteriores a esse
atual que mostraram que a o palmito
etanolamina isoladamente poderia ser
útil para enxaquecas,
que também isoladamente teve essa
redução da intensidade e a frequência
das mesmas.
Só que o estudo anterior não tinha um
grupo controle, o que tornava difícil
dizer com certeza que o pea tava sendo
benéfico, porque a frequência e a
intensidade das enxaquecas podem flutuar
ao longo do tempo.
Houve outro estudo também usando o Pea,
controlado randomizado, que mostrou que
esse produto estava ajudando a reduzir o
uso de antiinflamatórios como
ibuprofeno.
Porém, nesse estudo anterior, a redução
da dor era muito inconsistente
e o efeito era pequeno.
Bem, vamos ver aqui. Tá, tá, tá. Fiz
tudo que pedir e até agora 5 meses
depois nada. Só muito susto mesmo.
É, eu não peço esses exames, viu, Maria
Helena? Eu não, eu não gosto de pedir
esses marcadores tumorais. Eu acho que
eles dão muito estresse e pouco
resultado prático, tá? Eu sugiro que
você não fique fazendo muita
desses exames aí de rotina.
Envi uma pergunta pelo formulário. Vamos
lá.
Hessa
pergunta aqui. Dizem que o motivo de
surgirem muitas doenças respiratórias no
inverno é porque no inverno os vírus se
espalham com muito mais facilidade.
Porém, recebeu informação de que os
principais motivos são esses.
frio, as pessoas comem mais coisas
quentes, hambúrguer, cachorro quente,
pizzas salgadas, etc. A procura por
esses alimentos quentes aumenta no
inverno e por isso a imunidade cai. É um
fator, né? Se a pessoa tá comendo mais
alimento inflamatório, né? Produto
industrializado, processado no inverno,
que eu acho que é verdade sim, porque as
pessoas geralmente têm mais fome no
inverno, isso pode interferir com a
imunidade, com certeza. Outro motivo é
porque no inverno as pessoas se cobrem
mais, usam mais casaco, usam mais calça
que bermuda, cobrem o pé com mais
frequência, usam luvas,
isso diminui a exposição ao sol, recebe
menos vitamina D.
Faz todo sentido.
Faz todo sentido, Eliseu. Da imunidade
cai mais ainda. Eu acho que são fatores
adicionais, tá?
Na verdade, o são fatores adicionais,
mas o principal fator é que no inverno
as pessoas sofrem mais choque térmico,
né? E esse choque térmico leva à queda
da imunidade,
apesar de que muita gente faz choque
térmico propositalmente para aumentar a
longevidade, mas é um contexto
diferente, né? Então, no inverno, as
pessoas
tem essa questão do choque térmico, tem
a questão da poluição também. No inverno
a poluição aumenta muito
porque causo daquele fenômeno de
inversão, né, que a poluição fica mais
próxima ao solo e as pessoas têm mais
contato com o ar poluído durante o
inverno.
Não, não é conversa fiada não, Eliseu.
Não é conversa fiada. O vírus, na
verdade, tá o ano inteiro, tá? Mas ele
acaba infectando mais no inverno por
esses motivos todos, que é da de
imunidade, mais poluição, choque
térmico, tá?
Tenho muita dor de cabeça, posso
aumentar até quanto a melatonina?
Depende. Melatonina para câncer a gente
usa em doses por super altas, né? Então
você poderia aumentar quase que
infinitamente a melatonina se você não
tiver efeito colateral,
tá? Então, não sei que dose tá tomando
agora, mas eh tem gente que toma mais de
50 mg por dia de melatonina por conta de
câncer. Já vi até a dose de 300 mg de
melatonina.
Certo.
Mas o Reinaldo tá aqui no grupo do
WhatsApp, não entrou no não entrou na
live.
Mais perguntas? 10 mg. Você pode dobrar
essa dose, viu? Tranquilamente.
Pode dobrar essa dose tranquilamente.
Eu vou discutir mais um artigo, a gente
vai encerrar aqui, tá? Se vocês não
tiverem mais perguntas.
Olha,
aqui é bem interessante. Olha, tempo de
tela afeta o desenvolvimento social,
emocional de crianças abaixo de 5 anos?
Eu acho que a resposta é sim, mas vamos
ver aqui. É uma metaanálise de três
estudos observacionais. Incluíram 26.000
crianças
com menos de 5 anos.
E sim, o tempo maior de tela foi
associado a um desenvolvimento
socioemocional
pior. Olha só, eu também isso aqui
eu acho que era praticamente óbvio, né?
É um estudo que foi conduzido na
Finlândia, outro na China
e o outro
foi conduzido em oito países europeus.
São três estudos, um China, um Finlândia
e outro um consórcio de oito países
europeus juntados nessa metanálise,
né, juntos, né, nessa metanálise, deu
esse resultado aí que eu acabei de
falar.
Então eles usaram questionários
para avaliar o desenvolvimento
socioemocional em quatro domínios:
hiperatividade,
problemas emocionais, problemas de
conduta, ou seja, quebra de regras e
problemas com os colegas.
E o desenvolvimento socioemocional se
refere à habilidade de comunicar emoções
e estabelecer conexões com outros.
Então, quanto mais tempo nas telas, seja
televisão, tablet,
mais problemas. Então, esse tempo longo
de tela foi associado com os seguintes
problemas: 40% maior risco de
hiperatividade,
21% risco maior de problemas emocionais.
E também mais tempo de tela foi
associado com maior probabilidade de
problemas de conduta e problemas com os
colegas, mas não estava claro se esses
achados foram
estatisticamente significantes, porque
houve algumas discrepâncias de dados no
estudo.
dentro da análise da metaanálise, um
estudo foi classificado como de boa
qualidade e dois estudos de qualidade
média.
Então, o que que eles estão dizendo
aqui? que eles estão entendendo que
a exposição a telas
aumenta esse estímulo audiovisual,
que muitas vezes é intenso. E esse nível
auto de estimulação pode levar
a uma sensação de que a vida real é
menos interessante. Olha que
interessante.
Quer dizer, a tela com muito estímulo
faz a criança ter menos interesse pelo
mundo real.
Isso reduz os níveis de atenção.
E mesmo telas no background, né, telas
que estão no fundo, né, não estão no
primeiro plano, podem afetar as
crianças,
reduzindo o tempo de interação social.
E isso pode atrapalhar o desenvolvimento
social dessas crianças e reduzir as
oportunidades de comunicação e de
construção de
talentos sociais.
As skills, né? Famosas skills.
Além disso, como eu tô cansado de falar
aqui no canal, né?
A tela vai piorar a qualidade do sono
e também
vai reduzir a atividade física, porque
para as crianças é muito tentador ficar
na tela, né? Então elas perdem interesse
pela atividade física,
né? É o que nós estávamos falando agora
h pouco, Eliseu, né? A luz azul das
telas pioram
o sono porque pioram a produção de
melatonina.
E obviamente vocês sabem que um sono
adequado, uma atividade física adequada
são benéficas para o desenvolvimento
socioemocional.
Aí mencionando estudos anteriores que
tiveram achados parecidos com presente
estudo, duas metanálises grandes
anteriores relataram correlações
estatisticamente significantes entre
tempo de tela e comportamentos de
agressão, assim como falta de atenção e
impulsividade, né? Sintomas de TDH.
Só que nesses estudos anteriores a
correlação não era tão forte,
sugerindo que tinha outros fatores
contribuindo.
Tá, que ele tá discutindo também os
tipos diferentes de conteúdos que também
podem ter diferentes efeitos, né? Por
exemplo, se a criança tá assistindo
algum conteúdo educativo com o cuidador,
tem um efeito completamente diferente
você assistir um conteúdo que não tem
efeito didático,
porque tem interação aí com o cuidador,
né? tá assistindo junto e o cuidador
interage perguntando coisas que a
criança aprendeu ou o que que a criança
entendeu.
E ele fala também, se a criança tiver
jogando um videogame com tela com
outros, né, um jogo assim colaborativo
ou até mesmo competitivo, poderia
estimular o comportamento social, mesmo
tendo tela no meio.
E o tempo de tela foi mais com TDAH em
meninos do que em meninas em uma
metaálise anterior.
Então os meninos têm mais risco para ter
DH.
Então esses estudos
anteriores tiveram esses achados. O
estudo corrente não conduziu análise de
subgrupo
para tipos de exposição a telas, porque
o tamanho da amostra não era tão grande,
eram só três estudos.
Aparentemente o videogame tem menor
associação com problema de
desenvolvimento socioemocional do que a
televisão.
A Associação Americana de Pediatria, né,
Academia, né? Americana de pediatria e a
Organização Mundial de Saúde estão
recomendando que as crianças com menos
de 5 anos tenha o máximo de 1 hora de
tempo de tela por dia, tá? A realidade
tá muito diferente isso aqui. E que
crianças abaixo de 2 anos não deve ter
nenhum tipo de tempo de tela.
E obviamente, né, vocês sabem que 99%
das famílias não estão seguindo essas
regras.
Aqui ele tá falando com um estudo de
2022, examinando 63 estudos anteriores,
ou seja, metaanálise estudando 63
estudos anteriores de uma variedade de
países.
Demonstrou-se que apenas 36% das
crianças abaixo de 5 anos e 25% das
crianças abaixo de 2 anos estavam
respeitando esses critérios. A questão
do Brasil é muito menos do que isso.
Provavelmente, como esse estudo foi
feito com questionários, as famílias
simplesmente mentiram ou,
né, tiveram dificuldade de lembrar o
tempo exato de tela, né?
Então essa é uma coisa muito muito
preocupante de hoje em dia.
Bem, vamos encerrar aqui, né?
Mas antes responder a última pergunta do
Eliseu.
Por que que alguns médicos recomendo 05
por dia para tomar noite dizem que três
é muito? Porque na verdade, Eliseu, você
tem que começar sempre com a dose menor
efetiva, tá? Se 05 tá funcionando, usa
05. Eu tenho vários pacientes que não
responde a 05, tem que aumentar a dose.
Então é individual, Eliseu, tá? Porque
algumas pessoas também com 3 mg já tem
aquela sensação de ressaca com a
melatonina. Beleza, pessoal? Obrigado aí
terem
participado. Peço desculpas aí por ter
me atrapalhado, não ter colocado essa
esse link da live com mais antecedência.
Semana que vem nós vamos fazer
direitinho. Um abraço para vocês. Uma
excelente semana.